Lily welcome to camp eat a fun-filled
adult experience with coloring books and
juice boxes love it everything I love
all right VidCon how many vidcon's is
this for you now this is my third vid
Connor
third behind what's different about this
year I think it's different because I
have friends you know the first couple
because I know friends I was a loner in
my room we didn't know anyone no scared
of other Creators but now I have like
real friends and I'm like hey let's hog
and stuff it's cool night because you're
now la-based I am well I don't think
that's the only reason I asked you vaso
your I think growing your community all
the unicorns I've gotten used to this
world and I've met a lot of people and
I've found the people who I think I
relate to alright so I know what the
movie came out this year mm-hmm
what are we doing to top it well you
know just some casual world domination
you know nothing major I'm working on a
lot of really exciting things but I
think one of the things are really
important to me this year is just
putting the focus back into my channel
you know I'm doing all this exciting
stuff outside of YouTube but I just love
making content still and I still want to
feed that amazing community and build
and so I'm just really taking the focus
back onto YouTube creating my to be as a
weekend making them awesome making all
those unicorns happy exactly and another
cool thing is I mean I saw you looking
at my lipstick I saw yes
and so I released my lipstick which is
really cool called box with Smashbox
well hey yeah so you can wear Lily you
know watch Lily oh and every day you can
meet them you know you have some movies
coming out I do I have a cameo in the
new Ice Age movie where I play two mini
corns you'd of course I I'm like exuding
unicorn this hey hey yeah Miss Teen
bubbles other names and then I have a
cameo in Mila Kunis is upcoming movie
called bad moms where I play a mom so
I'm playing maybe unicorns and a mom
something in your wheelhouse something
out of your house you know she's got a
core but it's a lot of fun I'm really
excited
I'll be watching you everywhere wearing
you meeting you appreciate it thank you
so much for stopping by we have the
first time ever been to camp
you've never been to camp apartment so
I'm glad we could be your first camp
experience